[Applause]
davis extends out and harris sticks
another yeah two big buckets here for
tobias harris
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
94-78
carmelo anthony is getting into it with
some fans here
just behind our broadcast area they've
been riding him for about four straight
possessions mello started looking in
their direction the conversation
continued and now mello has had enough
and began to move towards them
leon wood has stepped in with security
[Applause]
and there might be an ejection in play
here yeah it looks like it is security's
here the referees are
pointing at them and uh we've got a
couple of guys i think are going to get
thrown out i thought carmilla was coming
over here yelling at you
i saw him coming this way i said what is
it that ian said
that could have so upset carmelo anthony
it was just my general play-by-play
apparently but no this
this fortunately did not go beyond
what you're seeing there was a moment
there where anthony continued to charge
and
kevin cutler got in there
and security
then swarmed into the area to make sure
that it did not exacerbate leon wood
pointed to the fans
and they have been escorted
to the tunnel area now the question will
they be escorted out yeah they're gone
they are gone great job by both the
referees and
the security here in philadelphia
to squelch the situation